l'espace culturel de saint paul sera la
première salle à ouvrir le bal sur scène
ce soir davy sicard
l'artiste dévoile son nouvel album balle
kabar qu'il qualifie d' engager son séga
et maloya s'entremêlent demain le
spectacle prend une autre tournure cette
fois le chanteur élargit son public et
lui propose un concert connecter une
innovation pour s'adapter protocole
sanitaire
ils achètent leur place aux billetteries
habituelles et ils reçoivent un lien
unique qui leur permet de se connecter à
20 heures vendredi soir pour voir davy
sicard en live s'ils craignent de venir
dans la salle s'ils sont trop loin
toujours à l'espace culturel les 11 et
12 septembre
marie alice sinaman sera de retour sur
scène costa terlat est une croisière
sentimentale aux commérages quiproquos
et manigances à la créole feront le
bonheur des spectateurs aux côtés de la
reine de l'humour pays deux acolytes
eric fleurissent et où tout est nu
[Musique]
si mes pommes n'a point trop budget
chacun est heureux
direction le sud à présent on la rentrée
culturelle s'annonce riche au théâtre
luc donat lever de rideau demain avec le
spectacle des maillets sur scène le duo
florence voyez lino merrion puis la
musique rythmera le théâtre du tampon
avec meddy gerville qui revient le 26
septembre avec son album au maloya le
jazzman met l'accent sur ses racines
c'est tout ce que je fais
[Musique]
ces mots j'en suis à mon sixième et
aujourd'hui voilà je joue le mal être
additionnels pour inviter des gens à
découvrir en plus les amoureux de la
danse seront également gâtés avec le
spectacle et massiwa qui signifie les
îles en comorien
il ouvre de nouveaux horizons à la danse
hip hop en quatre tableaux vous
voyagerez dans cet archipel de l'océan
indien
rendez vous le 14 novembre prochain en
raison de la crise sanitaire de nombreux
spectacles ont été reportés mais la
programmation reste haute en couleurs
puisque vous aurez l'occasion de voir
des expositions de la poésie ou encore
des films lors des festivals à venir